don't even think about it drivers were
warned to stay off a major highway near
Portland Oregon following a multi-car
pileup in heavy snow an 18-wheel truck
jackknifed on a interstate highway in
Wyoming where a State Trooper barely
escaped being hit by another out of
control truck schools were closed in
Wisconsin Minnesota and South Dakota
where up to 40 centimeters of snow were
forecast they could be pretty rough as
we get towards the end of the week here
some 2000 flights were canceled on
Thursday and more than 13 thousand
delayed as the storm swept from coast to
coast our flat was originally supposed
to leave at around seven o'clock and we
got a text message after arriving here
early that our flat was going to be
delayed hardly any place was spared
Nature's Fury high winds whipped through
Las Vegas toppling power lines and
causing blackouts while we were working
and I was ringing and all of a sudden
the light just went poop while northern
states are used to Wild Winters unusual
freezing weather patterns dipped all the
way down to normally sunny Southern
California with snow falling on
elevations as low as 600 meters above
sea level and hail lashing a Los Angeles
County Beach Community up to four and a
half meters of snow are predicted in the
mountain areas across the state
California Water authorities hope the
heavy snowpack will replenish reservoirs
giving farmers and residents a respite
from years of chronic drought more heavy
snowfall is expected across the state
over the next several days Rob Reynolds
Al Jazeera Los Angeles